question 23 it costs a lot to produce
foreign our people investing in way
investigating ways semesters it actually
probably no longer does I think
Mitsubishi Company have a major plant in
Kyushu in South Island of Japan where
they're making large amounts of c60 and
at the moment its application a large
scale is is not great because we're
still trying to understand how to use it
and to some extent we must realize that
today we're an extremely advanced
technological age in which a huge amount
of funding has been put into certain
areas which are have been well developed
a good example would be computers
top-down technology which is not really
now the technology of this small scale
has produce computers and the camera
which is being used here and the
fantastic storage capability of modern
hard disks and flash memories now that
is the culmination of 50 years of work
on silicon based technology human
billions have been spent on it to
develop it to the art that it is at the
present time so if C 16 molecules can
replace this by molecular compute
they've got a long way to go a huge
amount of research has got to be put
into it to pull the industry to
changeover and so there's a big big
inertial barrier to overcome even if we
can do it and it's it should be possible
to produce a molecular computer which
maybe is 10 to 100 times smaller and one
dimension may be ten thousand times
smaller in two dimensions and a million
times smaller in three dimensions but we
we don't know how to do that yet but
this should be possible and but even if
we make the major technical breakthrough
in the development of the chemistry
we'll still have to go through all the
other aspects which are involved so I
say you make a molecular computer which
is a thousand times smaller than the
present computer they may not operate on
the same sort of software does it all
that software you can't you probably
won't be able to transfer it easily I
mean the brain it seems to be some sort
of computing machine but it seems to
work a lot differently from the way that
are very sort of serial machines work we
still don't understand the brain when we
do if when and if we do well we're
making a lot of progress and we'll see
that it's a very clever machine or
indeed doing things in ways that I think
modern computers can't cannot do it
probably cannot do it I don't know so
that's the thing I think Mitsubishi are
mass producing material and if it's
really going to have a bulk value then I
think it will be come down very very
easily in course they'll be it could be
a hundred times cheaper as long there
was a bulky application that's on the
cards but the moment that isn't the case